Hello, Frank Defratus.
How are you doing?
Hello.
Alec.
Yes, am I calling it a good time?
It's it's the uh prearranged time and you're right on the money.
Oh okay.
You're a minute early.
Oh.
Are things going well for you?
Yes.
This is the uh first show that I've ever done where someone has called me.
Oh really?
So I I was actually a little confused as to uh what I needed to do here.
You know, should I have headphones on when the phone rings?
I didn't even know if the phone would ring.
Because it it all goes into a mixer board, you know.
That's pretty funny.
So uh it seems like it turned out okay.
Okay.
Great.
Well, we have a lot of things to talk about.
I thought we would talk a little bit about the history of Integraph, cover a little bit about the company and also your announcement of your new laser diode systems that you're going to be bringing on the market soon.
But first, since you have the pulse of holography through your business, obviously.
Let me ask you a couple questions.
Sure.
Okay.
We'll make the answer simple.
Uh the answer would either be up or the answer would be down.
How's that?
Okay.
Uh holography and education.
Up.
Up?
That's good.
Professional use of holography.
Uh if you define broadly holography, well, I I was only up or down, right?
So that would be, I guess, overall up.
Up.
That's good too.
But if you're talking about holographic art, I think there's some potential there, as we've seen at the uh conference in Wales.
That was uh very actually very encouraging.
Yeah.
Amateur holography.
Up.
Definitely up on that, don't you think?
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
So we've got three ups there.
That's good.
That's right.
Always want to try and get a finger on the pulse of holography and where it's at.
Unfortunately, I haven't seen a hologram anywhere in ages outside of my own studio.
Yeah, you know, when you say it's up, but it's still uh probably a slow uh slope on that.
Mm-hmm.
Um I think education is it's growing, particularly in the in the junior highs and high schools as they're beginning to do that.
And we're finding a lot of summer camps bringing into it.
In fact, this past summer we helped a camp uh set up a lab and they taught over a thousand students uh making holograms.
A thousand number.
Wow.
What camp was this?
Uh let's see.
They had there's uh there's several actually there's three of them.
There's three summer science camps uh for kids, and each one of them had about three hundred, four hundred students uh making holograms.
Are they through museums?
Uh no, they're actually through universities that are trying to get uh some foundation money to help set up camps uh on optics and things like that, and holography is becoming a part of that, and we're helping them set up curricula and uh we give them pretty steep discounts too so that they can really make it affordable.
Yeah.
Well, you know, as far as careers go, it's it's holography is in and of itself, not too many people would probably suggest to someone to become a professional holographer, when there are so many other choices in physics and optics and photonics.
But holography is a wonderful segue to physics, optics, and those types of careers.
That's correct.
In fact, uh, I think uh my father, Dr.
Jung, uh aptly puts it, if the past century was a century of uh uh electronics, and you've seen how that's completely changed the world, the next century is really going to be the century of optics.
And where where else can you learn five Nobel uh you know prize winning uh uh ideas than in holography?
Mm-hmm.
And it's fun for kids, bottom line, that's very important to keep kids' interest.
That's right.
Because you're competing against MTV, you're competing against iPods.
Anytime you're in a classroom, you know, you may be talking about George Washington for a week, but it's just not going to cut it with some kids, you know.
But holography, it's something that they can bring one of their favorite objects into class and the workshop and do a hologram of it and put it under the light and see it, and everyone's very excited about it.
Right, and I think another thing that we oftentimes uh bring up, uh, particularly is some teachers will ask, you know, how can I set up my curricula?
What else should I teach besides how to make the hologram?
We have to bring it into the co you know, the uh the context of today in which you know you're looking at some of this new holographic um innovations, uh particularly in holographic storage.
If you look at holographic disk storage, you know, we're looking at making uh three hundred gigabyte discs to even terabyte, which is a giga gigabyte disk within the next couple of years.
And what is that based on?
It's based on holographic, you know, uh basically multi channel holograms.
And so there's a lot of application there, and then you also look, of course, at smart holograms and what they're doing with diabetes, treating diabetes or uh monitoring uh diabetes and other uh diseases.
There's actually a lot of applications of holograms that a lot of people actually are not as aware of and it's actually an important field and you'll see that I think holography will start uh uh you know not only becoming uh more used but I think it'll become more known as well.
Yeah, yeah.
Well hopefully.
Not too many people know anything about the magnetic hard drives within their PCs.
And uh not many people know about the uh the laser systems that are in the C D players and D V D players, so it'll probably be behind the scene and but at least people know that it's there.
People know that they do have a hard drive in the computer and they do have uh laser systems in their D V D players and C D players so I can see that as well, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I placed my first order with Integraph I believe in nineteen eighty two or nineteen eighty three.
How old were you?
Uh let's say that I would have been about fifteen then fifteen.
Did you help your dad out back then?
Oh yeah.
In fact uh I think you asked about the little history intergraph but I can also start about my own little history.
Sure.
Uh very interesting that I I think I've been living around holography all my life uh probably because my you know my father I guess started in the nineteen sixties.
Initially I was probably just the object of his uh hologram as uh with the Lloyd Cross uh you know the uh cylinder hologram my brother and my sister and I were in that.
That was my first exposure truly true exposure to holograms literally and figuratively.
But thereafter was helping uh my father on some of the workshops uh during the summers and then uh later on actually have participated I believe in five out of the seven symposia uh on international holography, ranging from as a young kid uh just being the bus boy uh to uh more recently, you know, attending it uh at a a uh at a higher level.
And so uh Intograph has been around uh for about actually almost thirty years and yeah, seventy three, right?
What's that?
Seventy three, I believe.
That's right.
And uh yeah.
And you asked for how it started.
Well basically, uh my father was you know, really trying to uh help education and help uh promote holography, and it turns out that as he was making holograms, many of his colleagues would ask him, Well, where'd you get the film?
And my father would give him a little piece here, a little piece there, and okay, no, here's some.
Well ends up that more and more people kept asking, Well, where'd you get the film?
That ends up in order to keep purchasing and spending time on it, we uh we need to go on a kind of cost plus basis because just too many inquiries started coming in.
Where did he get the film?
Uh at that time, uh he was uh getting some, I believe from AGFA.
Direct directly from AGFA.
That's right.
Uh directly from Agva and I believe there was a difference another supply, I believe it was Ilford actually.
Because we had uh in the in the past uh been distributors for Kodak, Ilford and actually the DuPont Polymer.
Yeah, his his early work probably was on Kodak.
Yeah.
I know there were an uh there were there were several distributors back in the early days.
Um one not too far from me here, which was Keystone Scientific.
Oh jee, and what were some of the other names?
The names uh just you know slip by me now.
Yeah, there was uh it's a it does still some of a niche industry, you probably notice.
It's uh haven't gotten its full bloom and so players have come in and out and uh somehow uh Indograph has uh I guess has survived and uh today it's um I think we're probably one of the few sh uh distributors around that kinda do it on a full time basis.
So we're able to you know basically ship the ni the same day.
So someone calls that morning, yeah, we can ship it out that next day.
Mm-hmm.
Uh so we've gotten to uh a scale that's large enough to be able to support that, but still I would say definitely a niche market.
Um still have to keep the prices at a certain level just to be able to to stay in.
It's it's unfortunate that the recording materials still you know, are so expensive.
When you when you take into consideration what the cost of, you know, all the other equipment needed to make a hologram, you know, someone can easily put a fairly decent experimental holography system together, like a little studio for a hundred dollars and then they're gonna spend, you know, two hundred and twenty dollars for a couple plates.
Yeah, it depends on the size of the plate, of course, but yeah.
The prices we tr pretty much try to maintain it.
I don't think we've actually had a price increase for something like five years.
Oh, it's not anything that you can do, you know, it's not your fault.
Yeah, it's a tough one.
It's definitely a tough cookie to crack because we're trying to make it more affordable.
In fact, so what we're doing is some of the new products that we have coming down the road, we're actually working with a manufacturer to produce some film.
Uh actually we're being very happy with the results.
Uh, we're finding it it's comparable to Agfa and actually uh the Fuji except that it won't be um it's not uh polychromatic, it's uh just red sensitive now.
But the idea is to have a high quality film come in at a price that's significantly lower than um what you know, customers were used to, at least with the Agva film.
Yeah, that's fantastic.
Um but still, you know, a higher quality for the same price is not a bad it's always not a bad thing.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
So you've got a lot of interesting new things coming up.
I was on your website, I actually want to get a box of plates from you, but I'm I'm leaving next week and I didn't want to order them when I was on the website uh because I didn't want them arriving, you know, while I was gone.
That's when I noticed your lasers.
Your new laser.
So why don't you tell the folks that are listening?
This is big news.
I mean that's a wonderful price.
It's it's almost science fiction when you think back ten, twenty years.
You know, fifty milliwatt, hundred milliwatt diode laser that you can probably put into your pocket.
And uh why don't you tell the folks what your plans are and uh keep in mind that this'll be up, you know, once once this show goes up, it stays up, so ten years from now, you know, people will be live listening to this show as well.
And then uh you know, ten years from now they'll say a hundred milliwatt for two you know for two hundred and fifty dollars for one dollar now.
But you know, yeah, we're pretty excited.
We've got a few new products coming out.
Uh one is the lasers.
We also have a new film I mentioned about called the Intergraph XT six thirty three film.
Uh new developer coming out covered JD X, which is pretty much a D nineteen mix uh type of thing, except that it's really to be used with a new film.
And then the lasers.
Oh, I'm I'm sorry, one more thing.
With the lasers we also have the lazy safety goggles because when you start working with lasers that high, we really recommend uh safety goggles and we put a automatic list price twenty percent lower than pretty much the uh any manufacturer we buy the best laser goggles from uh Trinity Technologies and put it down at twenty percent less just to really encourage the use of them but the um lasers we were coming out with one is a fifty milliwatt uh uh let's just put it so put it this way manufacture listed as uh or specified as fifty but as you know usually it doesn't come out fifty it comes out about thirty forty um but depending on how you you know you powered up and then they've got a hundred milliwatt which comes out really around eighty uh when you power it up but basically these are two uh down lasers very similar to the laser that we have now for thirty five dollars which is a four milliwatt in terms of having a a couple of things it's got a uh coherence length about one meter uh it's got frequency stability uh and so that makes it possible to make holograms in the first place.
Yes.
Uh and then third you also have the removable uh an adjustable collimating lens which is really a sweet feature because you can simply unscrew the lens and have the lights shine straight out.
Therefore you do not need the laser beam to go through any specific other lenses to spread the beam.
What you end up with is a beam that's extremely clear because it doesn't have to pass through four different surfaces, the laser lens nor the exterior lens.
And so if you're doing a Denisou cologram you can pretty much shine it like a flashlight make a hologram.
Uh of course you could put the lens back on and then do split beam as well.
In fact uh our technical director uh my father, Dr.
Jung, actually replaced his uh Heaney laser with this one.
And so we've got two of them.
One is a fifty, the other a hundred uh a hundred, and the hundred's gonna be uh probably gonna list it around around two forty five, two hundred dollars and forty five cents, which is, you know, like ten times more more than ten times cheaper than a compo laser you could buy if if it were not a diode.
Oh my goodness, yes.
And uh, you know, thousands of dollars versus two hundred and forty five.
And then the fifty milliwatt we're gonna list at about a hundred and seventy five.
Um we expect to have the hundred milliwatts within actually uh a few days to uh within a week.
Okay.
On some of the s uh the specs.
Uh we we found a little fault on it and we had to have it changed and the delay on the fifty or the one hundred?
On the fifty.
Okay.
And so uh we're trying to see uh when we can get that, but hopefully, you know, we we were originally expecting it like uh a couple weeks ago, but I think we're getting a little more delays.
We're gonna push that out a little bit.
But a hundred milliwatts should be ready soon, uh within a week actually.
Yeah.
And then we're gonna do just some final testing just to make sure that batch is the same.
Uh we've tested several batches now just to make sure that you know it's the same.
Yeah and it's working well.
But so far, really great results.
Um the one caveat I would say about the laser, uh, is that we've only tested up to uh exposures about thirty seconds.
Okay.
Um but remember, you know, we're talking about a hundred milliwatts, so it's not that often you're gonna do exposures longer than that.
Um but you know, we do find that with this with diode lasers, with any diode laser, there's always that temperature uh issue uh where you might get a little a shift.
And so uh so we've seen some fringes, unusual fringes, or actually things not happening when you go to exposure longer than that.
But for short exposures or contact copy, uh this laser does really, really well.
Yeah, and I I I imagine it's uh just in the single brass housing, similar to your other uh kit laser, right?
Uh that's right.
So uh single brass housing and this time we actually have the entire uh even the circuit housed.
I think in our on our smaller one, it's still not housed ideal.
But uh this one we've got housed so that you get a little more uh robustness in terms of and s you know and uh longevity on it.
Mm-hmm.
And simply the power source is again the same as before.
Two D battery and a battery holder.
And so it's really simple.
Is it possible to run it off of um a a D C power source, you know, like one of the wall warts.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Sure, you can certainly do that.
Uh you can still run it off that um some uh professors, teachers or those who have access to the you know electronics can certainly do that.
Um and it's also possible to run it through a TEC controller so you do have temperature, you know, stability.
Yeah.
And that should also fix the problem as well.
Great.
That's exciting stuff.
Yeah, really we're pretty excited about that.
And then uh we're also looking at some uh our current holo kit, as you know, you know, I think the is low at ninety nine dollars to make holograms is as a uh it's pretty uh probably one of the the most affordable up there today.
Um and then we've got of course the other two holo kits, you know, using plates.
But now we're looking at some what we call middle and higher end equipment as well.
And looking at for the next half year or so.
Middle end meaning there's a lot of people that are graduating from the holo kit.
The holo kit you can make six different kinds of holograms, but usually at a more basic level.
You know, you can do infrastrumy, transmission, reflection, even multi-channel with it.
But and uh but we're finding there's a lot of people that are graduating from that, want to move to the next level, but can't afford thousands of dollars of equipment.
And so we're looking at something that's in between probably near the four or five hundred dollars where you can get all the equipment all together uh to set up your lab.
And then finally we're looking at some really high end because we've got some schools and professors and that have, you know, foundation funds and really want the whole optical table as well.
So we're trying to put together some packages there as well.
Um the idea is really to make holograms and holography a little more accessible to to people at all levels, depending if you're a beginner or if you're an expert.
Yeah.
I don't know if this would be uh population density uh dependent or not, but do you find specific areas of the country that are more likely to be uh working with holography than others.
Huh, that's a good question.
Um I I actually we see a pretty good spread.
I think in the past it was probably very Chicago based, New York based and West Coast, right?
Uh uh but now what we're finding is actually uh Florida is beginning to do a lot of holography.
Well that's it's a requirement in Florida now beginning this year.
Right.
I don't know if you uh spoken to Bill Pugh, but he's done a fantastic job on there, really trying to push the importance of optics and holography down there.
And so we're we're uh we certainly uh speak to him uh on a frequent basis, and then we also find that uh uh new uh kind of the south is beginning to pick up, particularly Texas and New Mexico and things like that.
But generally speaking I think it's now fairly even, although there's concentrations of course in New York and the West Coast and uh Chicago.
Did you know there were four states where you have to register lasers if they're uh three B and above?
Uh yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know if people actually if folks actually go through the trouble of doing that, but I uh I was on the web the other night looking different things up and uh I believe it's New Jersey, New York, Texas, and Massachusetts.
Yep.
Yeah.
You can't even give a laser to someone else in New York if it's three B or above.
If you give a laser that's three B or above to another person in New York.
That's an offense.
Right.
I think one of the things actually I forgot to mention about the lasers we're having is we're gonna we are gonna have a we have a clause there that we on an occasion we'll need to deny uh sales to certain individuals.
Right now our the purpose of uh um having these lasers out is really for the experienced holographer who knows what they're doing, has these lasers uh and we're not really gonna be readily uh providing them for I guess youngsters or first timers uh especially first timers who have family and kids because yeah you know a a laser at that level yes it will hurt your eyes if you even look at it just for a split second so you really gotta know what you're doing.
And so we're gonna be we're trying to set up uh before we release it a a way of really informing people.
Hey, this is what it's about.
Do you know what you're doing?
And then and go from there.
Because we really want to take that and uh we're pretty serious about that.
Well in the old days that would be like someone purchasing a spectrophysics one twenty five.
You know, which ran at fifty milliwatts.
It was, you know, the spected fifty, usually put out more if the tube was new, but uh and it took two people to lift it, you know, one at each end.
And now you can just put it in your pocket.
That's right.
You know, for a hundred and some dollars for the fifty milliwatt, right?
Yeah, that's right.
Well I'm going to get one also.
Okay.
So uh hold one from I don't know if uh what you if you're back ordered or not, but hold one for me.
I'll be away next week but I'll be coming back the week after.
Yeah, we're actually right now putting together a email uh a mailing list uh because we've had a lot of inquiries about it and uh fortunately we had a couple delays so far but uh we'll definitely you know email everybody who has requested you know information on it the second they come in so that they know about you know they're ready to go and so forth.
Mm-hmm.
Just take a moment to explain once again your other products that you're bringing on the market that's new, especially the developer.
I uh I've seen some holograms, actually reflection holograms that have been uh developed with D nineteen and with the uh potassium dichromate bleach.
They're beautiful holograms.
You do get a wavelength shift down to the green, but that's okay too because the eye's most sensitive to the green anyway.
But uh does a real nice job.
And you said you have a developer kit that's coming together that's similar to D nineteen?
Well it is actually uh the the developer site is basically D nineteen um you know it's the the metal, uh sodium sulfite, the you know sodium carbonate and potassium bromide and so forth.
Relatively safe too.
Yeah, that's right.
And then we've got the uh then we have a bleach um which will be the uh copper bromide uh potassium sulfate uh citric acid and uh some potassium bromide um and that basically this formula with the the reason why we developed this formula is partly because we have the new film coming out and we found that this particular uh formula works best for that film.
We have not really tested this formula yet on others products but we are actually about to test it on some of the the Fuji, the uh uh and some of the slavish material.
Yeah.
Just to see how it works.
But basically it's uh made for the the new film, the XP six thirty three, which we don't even have on our website yet because uh we're still doing some final testing on it with some uh holography experts and things like that.
Yeah.
And what's the bleach that'll be associated with the processing of that new film.
Uh that is uh the bleach is actually very comparable if you've heard of a Kodak F5.
It's very similar to it.
Um and it is a copper bromide uh potassium sulfate uh citrus acid uh potassium bromide I see and it's right now the developing process is a little longer but it's for the ideal uh sake if for schools and uh individuals we still recommend uh you know going with a JD four with a P F G O three or J D two with Pf GO one because the developing is so fast.
Particularly the JD four I mean you can you we can swing out a hologram in less than two minutes exposure to developing.
Mm-hmm.
Uh and so a lot of schools actually still prefer that.
Well, is there anything else that you'd like to add?
I see we're coming up almost on thirty minutes, believe it or not already cow and I like I like you know, I would talk to you for hours, but I I like to keep the file sizes small because believe it or not, there are still people that are on dial up fifty-six K modems.
And uh you have to take file size into consideration.
So half hour audio file, you know, with someone downloading on a fifty-six K uh dial up modem, you know.
So anything you want to say or cover before uh we close out?
Well, I think the only thing I want to let uh people know is you know, of course, uh our our mission at Intergraph is really to make holograms known uh and of course accessible and too accessible, really trying to make things simple.
So we got a lot of articles on a website that you might people might be interested in how to make holograms step by step.
And then we try to keep prices at uh what we call affordable, meaning we don't try to really rob the bank.
We try to keep it reasonable, and you'll see that there's a lot of discounts.
We sponsor the holography forum uh for discounts as well.
Yeah.
And so forth.
And then finally we do provide a lot of technical support.
Uh we've helped people go from uh basically starting with a holography kit for ninety-nine dollars to now making full colour holograms to even someone's unprofessional, believe it or not.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, and so and it's all actually free technical support leading there.
And um and then the final word really want to say is hey, thank you, Frank.
I mean this is uh invaluable radio station and your website obviously is just invaluable.
What you've done was dialed laser holography to s you know, the education through this uh uh the radio show and your website is exactly the kind of things that we really believe in, which is holography's out there, and it's not that hard to do.
Uh you know, just a little reading and you can actually do it within an hour.
Yeah.
Exactly.
So thank you, uh Frank.
Well thank you.
It's nice to see another generation uh getting involved.
Yeah.
The the the little ones will be moving up into the uh into the field soon too.
I'm one of the old I'm not one of the old old timers.
I I just have one old behind my old timer so I I see so many new faces and new names and uh it it really is a new new era and uh and new generation and I I appreciate what you're doing and I probably wouldn't have been able to get involved with holography if it wasn't for your dad at his company as well.
You know I mean he made it easy at one point to order things and and get the things that I needed to get started because I was one of those people as well one time a long time ago.
I'm I've never met your dad yet.
Wow.
You know I I have to uh I would have loved to have gone over to the conference and uh I don't fly which is my problem you know on airplanes.
I don't fly on airplanes and uh it's it's it's taken away a number of opportunities for me but one day it'll be nice to meet everybody in holography.
I hope I get the chance to do that.
Yourself included that's right that's right definitely and uh you know if we swing by you know uh Pennsylvania sometime we'll we'll definitely try to stop by or absolutely come by we'll go out for dinner.
That would be terrific.
Yeah.
Doors always open likewise uh same address, same phone number and everything since uh nineteen eighty three when I uh first started the studio here.
So same thing.
All right.
Well, Alec, thank you very much for taking the time to come on the show.
And I have a link to your website and uh email address and just about anything else anybody would need to get in touch with you.
That sounds terrific.
All right, good luck with the lasers.
And you'll be getting an order from me as soon as I get back after my trip next week.
Will do, Frank.
All right.
All right, I'll have this up.
I'll have this up later tonight.
Sounds terrific.
All right.
Take care.
All right, thank you.
Good talking with you.
Bye.